the man behind the desk watched as the
cosmic horror before him paced back and
forth
ranting what can only be described as
his head
off i am the ultimate hive mind
my influence is everywhere though you
normally cannot feel it
i am he who waits behind the wall
when i break through those tiny cracks
in your reality
i am the very personification of decay
and destruction black ooze great
tentacles blood flowing from your eyes
my six mouths are ever screaming
and the seventh one shall sing the song
that ends the world my very
gaze is enough to drive mental madness
it moved in closer and made several
dramatic motions with its tentacular
appendages
it shall come to an end
my power goes far beyond that of any
other being
you can think of it worked its mass into
the small wooden chair
and glared at the man i am decay
i am destruction i
am
and i am coming multiple tentacles
slammed into the desk
so why can't i
the be of the scp foundation showed no
shock towards the black amorphous
monstrosity that sat before him
the piercing red light from the
pinpoints deep in the dark mass did not
faze him
instead they merely reflected off his
glasses in his bolding head as he looked
down at his desk
look he began riffling through a sheet
of papers
this is your fifth time attempting to
apply for a cp
status i don't know how many times i've
said this to you so listen
up this is the final time
we do not have any interest in taking
you in
you just don't work did you
not hear me
yes yes we've been through this before
you were the ultimate force of
destruction
and can end the world and all those
other qualifications you're always on
about
there's no need to repeat them again now
i'm not saying i encourage it but why
don't you just go and do something
dangerous if you want in so badly
do something dangerous
my work over the past few years has been
beyond
dangerous i have been living countless
innocent children to madness
caused suicides all over this world
and bled into anywhere i conflict
and you ask to do
something dangerous the black mass
rose up drawing on its awesome power
zolgo
stated the director flatly you find web
comics
and you corrupt them the abomination
from beyond the stars stared blankly at
the director
then sank back into his chair looking
defeated
why do you want to be an scp anyways
well besides i'll go through one of the
non-screaming mouths
that bloody slenderman has been
spreading
his image around for quite some time
now getting people talking about what he
does placing himself in photographs
inspiring stories the usual fear
he's even got his web series now
can you believe that yes said the
director waringly
cocking his head to the side but what
does that have to do with anything
i'm new to the whole eldritch
abomination
thing i need some publicity
the whole thing with the webcomics is a
start
but it's easy for people to use my
methods
and never mention my name and let me
tell you
it's a big mark against me
[Music]
how about an awkward silence settled
over the room as the director took off
his glasses and wiped them off with one
hand
while holding his forehead with the
other deep in thought
zalgo shifted nervously in his chair
awaiting the director's answer
at length the director places glasses
aside and began speaking
barring the fact that i refuse to
participate in some weird
contest of abominations there's one big
reason
as to why we cannot take you in
it's not a matter of money or difficulty
of containment
oh no we've got a cps like
682 and it's pocket change to keep it
locked up
even when it breaks out and since you
seem willing to cooperate with us you'd
be
easy as pie to contain as well no
it's that you're just not interesting
enough
zalgo seemed to boil with fury at this
statement and opened several mouths to
make her a tort
but the director held him off allow me
to explain
you are bursting with power and have
the capacity to end this world with
thought
that's all will and good for other
organizations but here at the scp
foundation we can't
just accept you on those criteria
it's far too much you're overpowered
you don't have a hook and quite frankly
you're boring
when you get down to it you just don't
fit in with our image
for a moment it looked as if zolgo was
ready to end the director right then and
there
a few tense moments passed the seconds
ticking away as slowly as they could
before his shoulders sank and the black
mass sighed
all right all right you win
i don't see myself out as the chair
scraped across the floor
the director said try warehouse 13
or maybe the chaos insurgency
i'm sure they'll be a little more
lenient than we are
zolgo gave a grant of thanks and was
gone having melted into the walls
the director allowed himself a few
moments of peace before calling out
next and preparing himself for the next
sob story
a colossal green man with a squishy head
and a long wavy
beard of tentacles squeezed his way into
the office and stuffed himself into the
chair
riffling through a few more papers the
director looked up and stated
thank you for joining me today mr
you